[Musique]
le château de maintenon a une mémoire
vivante celle de monsieur rhin dhr lui
et son épouse sont les derniers
propriétaires particuliers du domaine il
se souvient de son étape quand ils en
ont hérité en 1953 mais bombardements
juste après le en 45 et avant avait fait
que le château n'avait plus ni toi ni
fenêtres pratiquement beaucoup des
plafonds étaient effondrés la plupart
des portes intérieures étaient soufflées
néanmoins nous étions jeunes et
probablement un peu inconscient donc dû
nous sommes lancés dans le projet et
nous avons commencé en 53 des travaux
ils ont poursuivi les premiers travaux
engagés par l'état et ont consacré leurs
vies à redonner au château tout son
éclat
les employés le savent bien comme yvette
qui travaillent ici depuis 26 ans elle
nettoie elle seule en deux jours toutes
les pièces des tableaux jusqu'au sol
c'est une chance de travailler ici quand
même c'est pas une belgique ce lieu donc
je déconne depuis que je suis ici depuis
que voilà que je j'ai quand même connu
un petit peu madame est venu avec nos
pour faire la poussière et tout ça sur
les objets le château est si bien
entretenu que les visiteurs ne s'y
trompe pas leur nombre a quadruplé en
dix ans mais le passage et les
vibrations fragilise ta force les
parquets et certaines oeuvres qui sont
alors mis à distance
c'est un ouvrage de 17 111 qui a été
établi selon les règles qui étaient
établis par nam de maintenant à l'école
de saint cyr
alors pour mieux protéger les
collections comme ses 2200 livre le
château fait partie depuis l'an dernier
d'un nouveau programme européen de
conservation préventive
on a des experts qui viennent nous
donner un coup de main sur sur justement
la conservation préventive l'importance
de le faire in situ c'est pour voir
effectivement comment ça peut s'abîmer
par rapport à l'éclairage par rapport à
la chaleur par rapport au fait que l'un
des deux côtés du château et plus à
proximité de leur ai donc avec des taux
d'humidité qui sont importants un
problème d'humidité
c'est en partie ce qui avait détérioré
la voûte
de la grande galerie après avoir réparé
tout les stucs fissuré écailles
les restauratrices repeignent avec des
pigments soigneusement choisis et si la
retouche est difficile parce qu'on a des
modulations qu'on voit pas forcément
et puis parce que justement on est sûr
de la peinture décorative donc avec des
motifs très répétitif et en fait ben la
moindre imperfection se voit tout de
suite en fait nous savons beaucoup de
précision beaucoup d'exigence et donc
beaucoup de temps il leur faudra deux
ans pour restaurer la galerie la fin des
travaux est prévue début 2010